This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。在《回味过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜爱的作家一起。就像马尔科姆·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。1984年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts,
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts上收听《艰难学习》，
or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode of the psychology of your 20s, new listeners, old listeners. It's so great to have you here. Thank you for tuning in. Each week we like to break down some kind of event or experience or situation that we go through in our 20s
或在您获取播客的任何地方。大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十几岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎收听《二十几岁的心理学》的又一期节目，新听众，老听众。很高兴你们来到这里。感谢你们的收听。每周我们都会剖析我们在二十几岁时经历的某种事件、经历或情况，
and provide a bit of a psychological explanation to hopefully provide those of us who are listening, who are going through this with some comfort and with some education as well. So today we're going to talk about something a bit serious, but something I think is quite universal during this decade of life. And that's feeling unhappy. That's feeling that things aren't going particularly well, feeling a bit blue, feeling a bit down. I think our 20s are such a tumultuous decade, but they're also such an amazing decade. And sometimes, I don't know if you've had this experience, I definitely have. We look around at our lives and everything is going according to plan.
并提供一点心理学解释，希望能给我们这些正在经历这一切的听众带来一些安慰和教育。所以今天我们要谈论一个稍微严肃一点的话题，但我觉得在这个十年的人生中，这也是一个相当普遍的话题。那就是感到不快乐。那就是觉得事情进展得不是特别顺利，感到有点沮丧，感到有点低落。我认为我们的二十多岁是一个动荡不安的十年，但同时也是一个非常精彩的十年。有时，我不知道你们是否有过这种经历，我绝对有过。我们环顾四周的生活，一切都按计划进行。
Everything is going perfect. We have an amazing family. We have friends. We have a partner. We have a roof over our head. So many things to be grateful for. You know, maybe you've have your dream job.
一切都完美无缺。我们有一个优秀的家庭。我们有朋友。我们有伴侣。我们有遮风挡雨的地方。有那么多值得感恩的事情。你知道，也许你拥有了你梦想中的工作。
You've gotten into your dream course. Everything is perfect. And yet we just don't feel happy. Something is wrong. Even though we have everything that people see as indicators of happiness and indicators of success. something just doesn't feel quite right. I think that is such a common shared experience of those of us who are in our 20s right now. And often what accompanies that feeling, that feeling that we're not
你考入了你梦寐以求的课程。一切都很完美。然而，我们就是感觉不到快乐。有什么不对劲。尽管我们拥有了人们视为幸福指标和成功指标的一切。但就是感觉有些不对劲。我认为这对于我们这些正处于二十多岁的人来说，是一种非常普遍的共同经历。而伴随着这种感觉的往往是，那种我们不
happy despite having every reason to be is a sense of, you know, guilt and shame for not being grateful enough. A sense of confusion, you know, what's wrong with me that I can't fully appreciate and be in the present and feel grateful and enjoy this period in this decade of my life. But I think it's a really common experience, one that's not spoken about enough to, you know, have periods of really intense unhappiness. So if that is you, I really hope that this episode allows us to kind of break down some of the stigma and some of the confusion and the ambiguity around how normal it is to go through a period. it's like this and kind of break away from that sense of guilt and shame that accompanies it.
快乐的感觉——尽管我们有充分的理由快乐——带来的是一种负罪感和羞耻感，因为觉得自己不够感恩。一种困惑感，你知道的，我到底怎么了，为什么我不能完全感激并活在当下，感到感恩并享受我人生中这段美好的时光和十年。但我认为这是一个非常普遍的经历，一个没有被足够多地谈论的经历，那就是经历一段非常强烈的不快乐时期。所以，如果那就是你，我真心希望这一集能让我们解开一些围绕这种情况的污名、困惑和模棱两可，理解经历这样一段时期是多么正常，并摆脱随之而来的负罪感和羞耻感。
I think we can't always control our emotional reactions and our emotional state the same way that we can't always control our external world, the external stresses and expectations that are placed on us. So for those of us who are asking that very question right now, why am I not happy? This episode is for you. To feel. hopefully a little bit less alone if you're feeling a bit sad a bit blue a bit down and looking for an explanation but also looking for some encouragement i think you've come to the right place we can hopefully share a moment and be a little bit miserable together but then also think about what's next and how to get out of this rut i think the mission of this show from day one has been to
我认为我们无法总是控制我们的情绪反应和情绪状态，就像我们无法总是控制外部世界、施加在我们身上的外部压力和期望一样。因此，对于我们当中现在正提出那个问题的人——为什么我不快乐？这一集就是为你准备的。去感受。希望如果你感到有点难过、有些沮丧、有点低落，并且正在寻找一个解释，同时也正在寻找一些鼓励，能感觉稍微不孤单一点，我想你来对地方了。我们可以一起分享一段时光，一起度过一段稍微有点痛苦的时刻，但随后也会思考接下来该做什么，以及如何摆脱这个泥潭。我认为这个节目自第一天起，其使命就是
provide people like myself who are in their 20s with a space for vulnerability to kind of share the good, the bad, the ugly of this decade. And I've always, you know, tried to keep it quite vulnerable. I think if we're being honest right now, I'm definitely going through this and asking myself this question of like, why am I not happy? Why am I not happy? Like I should be. I have every single thing that I want, you know, this show, this podcast is doing so well. I get so many amazing, beautiful messages from people like yourself, from my listeners, telling me how much they enjoy it, feeling like they have a sense of community, I feel so grateful, you know, I've got a great job, I have the best relationships with my friends and my family that I've ever had.
为像我这样处于二十多岁的人提供一个展现脆弱的空间，来分享这个十年的美好、丑陋和糟糕之处。而且我一直以来，你知道的，都尽量保持相当的脆弱。我想如果我们现在坦诚相待的话，我确实正在经历这个过程，并且在问自己这个问题，比如，为什么我不快乐？为什么我没有像我应该的那样快乐？我拥有我想要的一切，你知道的，这个节目，这个像你这样的人、我的听众发来的那么多惊艳、美丽的留言，告诉我他们有多么喜欢它，觉得他们有一种社区感，我感到非常感激，你知道的，我有一份很棒的工作，我和朋友以及家人的关系是我有生以来最好的。
I feel so at peace, but there are still these really, you know, sad moments where nothing makes me happy. Something feels like it's missing the excitement of life. And the excitement of this really amazing moment just isn't really sinking in. And it's kind of an awful feeling. I, like, we'll admit, I'm kind of struggling at the moment. And I'm sure there are many of those of you who are out there who are listening to this, who are struggling as well.
我感到内心非常平静，但仍然会有这些非常、你知道的，悲伤的时刻，没有什么能让我快乐。感觉有什么东西缺失了，生活的兴奋感。而这个真正美妙时刻的兴奋感并没有真正融入内心。这真是一种糟糕的感觉。我，就像，我会承认，我目前正在挣扎。我相信你们当中也有很多人在听这个节目，你们也在挣扎。
I think this episode is really, I think the real, yeah, it's really about having a discussion. about this normalizing this experience and it provides me with this weird opportunity where I get to kind of say to you what I would want to say to myself the things that would bring me comfort, the things that would make me feel better. So I'm hoping that you're able to relate to what we're going to talk about today, some of the psychological explanations, the social, the cultural, the biological explanations for why we're unhappy. So let's talk about it. Let's talk about what it feels like when everything is going right, but we still can't seem to really appreciate
我认为这一集真的是，我认为真正的是的，它真的是关于进行一场讨论。关于这一点，将这种经历正常化，这为我提供了一个奇怪的机会，让我可以把我想对自己说的话对你们说，那些能给我带来安慰的事情，那些能让我感觉更好事情。所以我希望你们能对我们今天将要讨论的内容产生共鸣，包括一些心理学的解释，关于我们为什么不快乐的社会、文化、生物学解释。所以让我们来谈谈吧。让我们来谈谈当一切都在顺利进行，但我们似乎仍然无法真正欣赏
that moment. That's what we're going to discuss today. Why do we find ourselves in periods of unhappiness or so-called depressive seasons? And what is the psychological explanation behind that? We're going to talk about what it means to be happy, what the definition of happiness is, why it's so subjective, you know, some of the biological and environmental and cultural reasons why we might be experiencing a really depressive and low period. But then also some of the ways that we can kind of move on from that, some of the ways that we can expand our horizons, expand our vision in a healthy way,
那一刻时是什么感觉。这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。为什么我们会发现自己处于不快乐的时期或所谓的抑郁期？这背后的心理学解释是什么？我们将讨论快乐意味着什么，快乐的定义是什么，为什么它是如此的主观，你知道的，导致我们经历真正抑郁和低谷期的一些生物学、环境和文化原因。但同时也会讨论一些我们可以从中走出来的方法，一些我们可以以健康的方式扩展视野、开阔眼界的方法，
in a way that is sustainable, in a way that is validating of our emotions and our experiences. We're all about vulnerability here, but we're also all about growth. So if this is you, if you relate to any of the things that I've talked about, you're in the right place. strap in. I'm excited. Let's learn some things. Let's be a little bit miserable, be a little bit sad together today and hopefully come out the other end. So I think it's pretty appropriate to
以一种可持续的方式，以一种证实我们的情绪和经历的方式。我们在这里讲究的是脆弱，但我们也讲究成长。所以，如果这就是你，如果你跟我谈论过的任何事情产生共鸣，你来对地方了。系好安全带。我很兴奋。让我们学习一些东西。让我们今天一起度过一段稍微有点痛苦、稍微有点悲伤的时光，并希望能从另一端走出来。所以我认为，
begin this episode by talking about happiness and maybe even talking about the definition of happiness. It's such an elusive kind of emotional state, such an elusive word. I think the thing that's really interesting about happiness is that it's one of those weird for phenomena when we only really know it and can recognize happiness when we feel it and we only really are conscious of it during its absence. You know, there are so many periods in life where, you know, we're neither happy, we're neither sad and we don't really seem to think about it much, but it's during those low points and during those really high points that we're quite, you know, happiness is really on our mind and we're really thinking about it. I think happiness is also
用探讨快乐，甚至探讨快乐的定义来开始这一集是非常合适的。这是一个如此难以捉摸的情绪状态，一个如此难以捉摸的词。我认为关于快乐，真正有趣的是，它是那种奇怪的现象之一，我们只有在感受到它时才真正了解并能认出快乐，而且我们只有在它缺席时才真正意识到它。你知道的，生活中有很多时期，你知道的，我们既不快乐，也不悲伤，我们似乎并不怎么去想它，但正是在那些低谷期和那些真正的高峰期，我们相当，你知道的，快乐真正占据了我们的脑海，我们在认真地思考它。我认为快乐也是
really hard to create artificially. You know, we might try. through self-care and exercise and eating healthfully and receiving physical touch and support and comfort from our loved ones. And that's amazing. But sometimes we're in such a state where that can only go so far. And of course, there are also so many unhealthy practices that we also engage in sometimes, like impulse shopping and alcohol and drugs and meaningless physical connection. And although we know that those don't really create long-term happiness,
很难人为地创造出来的。你知道的，我们可能会尝试。通过自我关怀、锻炼、健康饮食、接受来自我们爱的人的身体接触、支持和安慰。这太棒了。但有时我们处于这样一种状态，这种努力只能起到有限的作用。当然，有时我们也会从事许多不健康的实践，比如冲动购物、酒精、毒品和毫无意义的身体接触。尽管我们知道这些并不能真正创造长期的快乐，
it really does contribute to this understanding of like this kind of recognition that all of us really want to be happy and it's something that's really hard sometimes to get to. So what exactly do we mean when we talk about happiness, almost from a scientific perspective, what is, you know, the science of happiness? There is so much, I think controversy and ambiguity and confusion around what does it really mean to be happy, you know, is it the absence of sadness, the absence of struggle, or does it mean, you know, a lot of pleasure or materialism and comfort? And this is a debate that I think we haven't really gotten to the bottom of,
但它确实有助于形成这样一种理解：所有人都真的想快乐，而这有时确实很难达到。那么，当我们谈论快乐时，确切地说是什么意思呢？几乎从科学的角度来看，什么是，你知道的，快乐的科学？我认为，关于快乐的真正含义，存在着如此多的争议、模棱两可和困惑，你知道的，它是悲伤的缺席、挣扎的缺席，还是意味着，你知道，大量的快乐或物质主义和舒适？我认为这是一个我们还没有真正弄清底细的辩论，
and I don't think we ever will. But let's talk about some ideas or definitions of happiness. Some of the conceptualizations of what it means to be, you know, quote, unquote, happy, before we jump into sadness and unhappiness. If you think about it, I think the subjective nature of happiness makes it so incredibly difficult to define. kind of the problem. There have been, you know, so many discussions throughout the centuries about what happiness really means because it is such an elusive subject. You know, Aristotle
而且我认为我们永远也不会弄明白。但让我们来谈谈关于快乐的一些想法或定义。在深入探讨悲伤和不快乐之前，谈谈关于如何成为，你知道的，所谓的“快乐”的一些概念化理解。如果你仔细想想，我认为快乐的主观性质使得它极其难以定义。这可以说是问题的核心所在。几个世纪以来，有（你知道的）那么多的讨论，关于快乐究竟意味着什么，因为这是一个如此难以捉摸的主题。你知道，亚里士多德
had this idea that happiness could be actually conceptualized or composed of two different things. It wasn't just one feeling. It was both pleasure and a sense of life that is well lived. And we needed both of those, both immediate pleasure and also a sense of purpose to be happy. I think that really kind of gets to the core of what this feeling is. You know, we can have all the pleasure that we want. We can have an abundance of delicious food, an abundance of sex, an abundance of static feelings and of happy experiences. But if at the end of the day we go home and we don't really have any ambition, we don't really know where we're going, we have a sense of being lost or of not having any purpose, it's hard to be happy, you know, without that. And, and, you know,
有这样一种观点，即快乐实际上可以被概念化或由两件不同的事情组成。它不仅仅是一种感觉。它既是快乐，也是一种生活过得很好的感觉。我们需要这两者，即即时的快乐和目标感，才能感到快乐。我认为这确实触及了这种感觉的核心。你知道，我们可以拥有我们想要的所有快乐。我们可以拥有丰富的美味食物，丰富的性爱，丰富的好感和快乐的体验。但如果到头来我们回到家，却没有任何野心，不知道自己要走向何方，有一种迷失方向或没有目标的感觉，很难感到快乐，你知道的，如果没有这些。而且，而且，你知道，
it kind of goes the same way. You know, if we have this really intense mission, this thing that we're working towards, but we don't allow ourselves to have those small pleasures throughout the day, it's going to be pretty hard to be happy in that instance as well. I think they both contribute equally. And there's also that other element of happiness requires even a deeper feeling of being safe and secure in order to be achieved. I think when I think about happiness, I often think about Maslow's hierarchy of needs. So for those of you who don't know what this is, it's kind of this, it's a theory more about motivation and what motivates people to kind of self-actualize and to become their highest selves. But it also applies to happiness really, really well. So basically,
情况也差不多。你知道，如果我们有一个非常强烈的使命，一个我们正在努力实现的目标，但我们不允许自己在一天当中享受那些小小的快乐，那么在这种情况下，要感到快乐也是相当困难的。我认为这两者做出了同等的贡献。而且还有快乐的另一个要素，那就是需要一种更深层次的安全感才能实现。当我想起快乐时，我经常会想到马斯洛的需求层次理论。所以对于那些不知道这是什么的人来说，这是一种关于动机的理论，以及是什么激励人们去实现自我实现并成为他们最高的自我。但它也非常非常适用于快乐。所以基本上，
Maslow constructed this hierarchy. And at the bottom was our most simplistic, basic needs, you know, things like food and clothing and shelter. And then there was safety, so things like things like job security being, you know, not threatened, not having this sense of impending doom, love and belonging, you know, we need friendship, we need family. And then there was those kind of high, top of the tier components of happiness, esteem and self-actualization. And only when we achieve those bottom components of the hierarchy, are we actually able to achieve self-actualization?
马斯洛构建了这个层次结构。最底部是我们最简单、最基础的需求，你知道的，比如食物、衣服和住房。然后是安全，所以比如像工作安全感，不受到威胁，没有这种迫在眉睫的厄运感，爱与归属感，你知道，我们需要友谊，我们需要家庭。然后是快乐那些高阶的、顶层的成分，尊重和自我实现。只有当我们实现了层次结构中的那些底层成分时，我们才能真正实现自我实现？
Are we actually able to achieve a state in which we feel, completely secure and, you know, completely happy within ourselves. You know, the needs lower down in the hierarchy must be satisfied before we can attend to the needs that are higher up. This model, I think, can explain why happiness can be so difficult to find and why it is sometimes not just elusive, but actually quite, yeah, not just elusive, but actually quite difficult. You know, we, it's really hard to be attending to every single aspect of this day in and day out. I think sometimes we also see happiness as material and as the physical contents of our lives. We're satisfied when we have a good job and we have heaps of friends, a place where we feel safe and money to spend things and on things that we want.
我们才能真正达到一种状态，在这个状态中我们感到完全安全，并且，你知道的，在内心完全快乐。你知道，必须先满足层次结构中较低的需求，然后我们才能关注较高的需求。我认为这个模型可以解释为什么快乐会如此难以寻找，以及为什么它有时不仅难以捉摸，而且实际上相当，是的，不仅难以捉摸，而且实际上相当困难。你知道，我们，日复一日地去关注这天底下的每一个方面真的很不容易。我想有时我们也把快乐视为物质以及我们生活的物质内容。当我们有一份好工作，有很多朋友，一个让我们感到安全的地方，以及有钱把钱花在想要的东西上时，我们就感到满足了。
I think that's quite a shallow version of it. I would probably endeavour to say that people who see happiness as just the material or, kind of visual aspects of their life are never going to be able to maintain that happiness sustainably. But what happens when you do have everything? You know, we've talked about these different definitions of having vision and having passion and having security and pleasure and material items. What happens when you have that all? When you survey your life and you realize that for all intents and purposes. Anyone else, any stranger, any acquaintance looking in
我认为这是一种相当肤浅的版本。我可能倾向于说，那些把快乐仅仅视为生活中的物质或视觉方面的人，永远无法以可持续的方式维持这种快乐。但是，当你拥有了一切时会发生什么呢？你知道，我们已经讨论了拥有愿景、拥有激情、拥有安全感、快乐和物质物品这些不同的定义。当你拥有这一切时会发生什么呢？当你审视自己的生活，意识到出于所有的意图和目的。别人，任何陌生人，任何熟人看过来
would think that you're the happiest person alive, but you just don't feel that way. Like you just can't say it. You just can't say it that way. I think often when nothing external is going wrong, we look for an internal explanation, often to do with an irregularity with our neurotransmitters and our hormones,
都会认为你是活在这个世上最快乐的人，但你就是没有这种感觉。就像你就是无法那样说。你就是无法那样说。我认为通常当外部没有任何事情出错时，我们会寻找内部的解释，通常与我们的神经递质和荷尔蒙的失调有关，
and we like to kind of say that that is what's causing this inexplicable sadness or a low period, you know, from a dopamine in a biological perspective. I think it's also important to say here that being unhappy is not the same as depression. I think that's a really important distinction. Unhappiness and moments of sadness is very different to a diagnosed depressive disorder. I think feeling sad is a natural reaction to situations where we should feel emotional or upset. should feel pain. And that is completely normal, you know, without sadness. We wouldn't be able to experience the, you know, the joys of life. It's important to put things into perspective,
我们喜欢把这当作导致这种莫名其妙的悲伤或低谷期的原因，你知道，从多巴胺和生物学的角度来看。我认为在这里同样重要的是要指出，不快乐并不等于抑郁。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。不快乐和悲伤的时刻与被诊断出的抑郁症有很大不同。我认为感到悲伤是对我们应该感到情绪化或心烦意乱的情况的一种自然反应。应该感到痛苦。这是完全正常的，你知道，如果没有悲伤。我们将无法体验到，你知道，生活的欢乐。把事情放在正确的视角来看待是很重要的，
but it's also an important part of our brain and an important part of our emotional spectrum to use. But much like other emotions, sadness is temporary and it should fade with time. But it becomes a problem when we find ourselves in these prolonged, periods of sadness that are really difficult to get out of. And that's when we kind of enter into a discussion of depression. It's a mental illness. It's a long-term mental illness that impairs how we function in our day-to-day life and how we function in society. It's not something that can be overcome even when we try. It's not something to do often with our circumstances. It's something a lot deeper. And I think the difference between sadness and a depressive episode
但这也是我们大脑的重要部分，是我们应该利用的情感光谱的重要部分。但就像其他情绪一样，悲伤是暂时的，它应该随着时间消逝。但当我们发现自己陷入这些漫长的、难以走出的悲伤时期时，这就成了一个问题。而这正是我们开始讨论抑郁症的时候。这是一种精神疾病。这是一种长期的精神疾病，会损害我们日常生活的运作方式以及我们在社会中的运作方式。这不是通过努力就能克服的事情。这通常与我们的环境无关。这是更深层次的东西。我认为悲伤与抑郁发作
or depression is that sadness can often be treated. You know, sadness is an emotional state, whereas depression is a mental disorder. And when it's left untreated, it can really, really impact on our life. You know, for those of us who have experienced it, we often see this lack of interest and enjoyment in the things that we love, you know, insomnia, trouble eating, you feel really restless and really agitated and tired and this sense of worthlessness. It's a lot more than just feeling really sad. And I think it's an important distinction to make if we're going to talk about unhappiness. And if you think your sadness and level of unhappiness might be more serious than just a hard period or a hard season of life, I do think it's important to seek clinical help
或抑郁症之间的区别在于，悲伤通常是可以处理的。你知道，悲伤是一种情绪状态，而抑郁症是一种精神障碍。当它得不到治疗时，真的会严重影响我们的生活。你知道，对于我们这些经历过它的人来说，我们经常看到这种对我们喜爱的事物缺乏兴趣和享受，你知道的，失眠，进食困难，你感到非常烦躁、焦虑、疲惫，还有这种无价值感。这远不止是感到非常悲伤。而且我认为，如果我们要谈论不快乐，这是一个需要做出的重要区分。如果你认为你的悲伤和不快乐的程度可能比一段艰难的时期或人生的艰难季节更严重，我确实认为寻求临床帮助是很重要的，
and to kind of reach out to a more professional kind of networks. and it kind of leads to this deeper discussion of why is it that when everything's going right, we feel so sad. And often we like to say that it's a chemical imbalance. That's one kind of perspective. It's one explanation. It's often said that depression kind of results from a chemical imbalance. Things in your brain just aren't kind of matching upright. You don't have enough of what you need to feel happy.
并且去接触更多专业级别的网络。并且这导致了更深层的讨论：为什么当一切都进展顺利时，我们却感到如此悲伤？通常我们喜欢说这是化学物质失衡。这是一种视角。这是一种解释。人们常说抑郁症源于化学物质失衡。你大脑中的东西没有正确匹配。你没有足够的让你感到快乐的东西，
but I think that that is quite a simplistic explanation. Depression doesn't just spring from simply having too much or too little of certain brain chemicals. There are many other causes, you know, external causes as well. And there are so many forces in our lives that can kind of impact us to go through periods of not just intense sadness, but intense unhappiness. And chemicals are definitely involved. I think sometimes if we're looking for an explanation, it can be the right one. We need neurotransmitters and chemicals in our brains to allow us to function.
但我认为这是一个相当简单的解释。抑郁症并不仅仅源于体内某些大脑化学物质过多或过少。还有许多其他原因，你知道的，外部原因也是如此。我们的生活中有很多力量会影响我们经历不仅是强烈的悲伤，还有强烈的不快乐时期。化学物质绝对参与其中。我想有时如果我们正在寻找解释，这可能是正确的解释。我们需要大脑中的神经递质和化学物质来让我们正常运作。
And when those chemicals aren't at the right level, when they're not being released at the right time or in the right amount, that's when we can experience some really intense lows. There are millions of chemical reactions that make up our minds and make up our mood and our perceptions and how we experience life. So sometimes if we are in a period of really intense sadness and you're asking that question, that question we're asking ourselves of why am I unhappy? It could be a biological explanation.
而当这些化学物质没有达到正确的水平，当它们没有在正确的时间或以正确的数量释放时，我们就会经历一些非常强烈的低谷。构成我们思想、情绪、感知以及我们体验生活方式的，是数百万个化学反应。所以有时如果我们处于一段非常强烈的悲伤时期，并且你正在问那个问题，也就是我们一直在问自己的问题——为什么我不快乐？这可能有一个生物学的解释。
Sometimes it has nothing to do with you. It has nothing to do with your outlook, nothing to do with how hard you're trying or all the things you're putting in place. You know, neurotransmitters like dopamine and serotonin just aren't where they should be in your brain. And if you want to hear a little bit more about that, I actually did an episode on antidepressants, which is really interesting and talks about this a little bit further.
有时这与你无关。这与你的前景无关，与你多么努力或你所采取的所有措施无关。你知道，像多巴胺和血清素这样的神经递质只是没有达到你大脑中应有的水平。如果你想听更多关于这方面的内容，我实际上做过一期关于抗抑郁药的节目，非常有趣，并对此进行了更深入的讨论。
But let's kind of move beyond that explanation and talk about some of the environmental and social and cultural factors that can create almost an inexplicable unhappiness in our day-to-day lives. One of the big ones that I've seen so often with my friends and with my family that I think might be an explanation and could maybe even point you in the right direction as to why you're feeling this way is just existential dread. There is so much going on in the world right now. So many events, so many things that are really, really terrifying and pose an existential threat to our existence as humans. You know, it can be really hard to wake up each morning and feel positive and feel like what you're doing with your life is making an impact if we think about climate change, if we think about
但让我们超越这种解释，谈谈一些环境、社会和文化因素，这些因素可能会在我们日常生活中造成一种莫名其妙的不快乐。我在朋友和家人身上经常看到的一个大问题，我认为这可能是一个解释，甚至可以指引你朝着正确的方向去理解你为什么会有这种感觉，那就是存在主义焦虑。现在世界上发生了太多事情。那么多的事件，那么多真正非常可怕并对我们作为人类的存在构成生存威胁的事情。如果你考虑到气候变化，如果你考虑到
you know, all the wars that are going on at the moment if we think about things that are happening in Iran and all over the world, the injustices, that kind of plague our society. And it can really get us down. Existential dread is kind of bad dread about the state of the world and where you see yourself in it. And sometimes it can contribute to an existential crisis. And that's this feeling of unease about the meaning of life, about your purpose in life. You know, if everything else is going to shit. You know, if the climate is kind of unable to be turned around, if humans are creating these massive changes to our ecosystems and to our way of life, what's the point of, you know, giving it fuck, what's the point of trying if life is kind of inherently pointless?
你知道，目前正在发生的所有战争，如果你考虑到伊朗和世界各地正在发生的事情、祸害我们社会的种种不公，每天早晨醒来要感到积极乐观、觉得你生命中所做的事情正在产生影响，可能会非常困难。这真的会让我们情绪低落。存在主义焦虑是一种对世界现状以及你在其中所处位置的糟糕焦虑。有时它会导致存在主义危机。这就是那种对生命意义、对你在生活中目标的内心的不安感。你知道，如果其他一切都变得一团糟。你知道，如果气候无法扭转，如果人类正在对我们的生态系统和生活方式造成巨大的改变，那么，你知道的，去他妈的有什么意义，如果生命本质上毫无意义，那么努力还有什么意义呢？
That can be a really dark place to go to. And sometimes we don't even consciously realize when the negativity we see in the media and from the news is kind of getting. into our brains and getting into our outlook. I think that kind of links to another point. Our lives have been fundamentally changed by things like social media. It has allowed us to be connected to the world in sometimes a really artificial and unnatural way. And not only does it elevate the amazing things that people are doing and elevates our ability to compare ourselves to others, but it also elevates all the horrible things that are going on in the world. And it creates this really kind of inorganic second world for us to live in where everything is heightened,
那可能会是一个非常黑暗的去处。有时我们甚至没有有意识地意识到，我们在媒体和新闻中看到的负面情绪是如何进入我们的脑海并影响我们的前景的。我认为这与另一点有关。我们的生活已经被社交媒体等事物彻底改变了。它让我们以一种有时非常人工和不自然的方式与世界连接。它不仅提升了人们正在做的惊人之举，提升了我们与他人进行比较的能力，还提升了世界上正在发生的所有可怕事情。它为我们创造了一个真正意义上的、非自然的第二世界，在这个世界里一切都被放大了，
everything is intense. And that also has to do with comparison and this internal comparison game we play. It can be really hard to, you know, be happy with where you are and to be happy with what you have when we're constantly playing this internal comparison game and comparing our experiences and our emotional state to others. When we're used, used to judging our happiness from a point of relativity rather than from a place of honesty and a place of looking inwards, that can really do a number on our happiness and our sense of satisfaction. And social media makes that so much easier to do. Every day we're kind of forced to see these like amazing lives of our friends and celebrities and people that we know.
一切都非常强烈。这与比较以及我们玩内部比较游戏也有关。当我们不断地玩这种内部比较游戏，将我们的经历和情绪状态与他人进行比较时，要想对自己所在的地方感到快乐，对自己拥有的东西感到快乐，可能会非常困难。当我们习惯于从相对性的角度而不是从诚实和向内看的角度来判断我们的幸福时，这真的会对我们的幸福感和满足感造成极大的打击。而社交媒体让这一切变得容易得多。每天我们都不得不看到朋友、名人和我们认识的人那些令人惊叹的生活。
And it's a highlight real. Like I don't need to say that I think everyone knows. It's a highlight reel of other people's lives and all the amazing things they're doing. And it can be really easy to sit back at the end of the day and think, like, why is my life not that perfect? Why don't I have this? Why don't I have these experiences? And it can be a huge contributor to this sense of unhappiness in our 20s. I think we talk about this quite a lot on this show.
这是一个高光时刻集锦。就像我不需要说的那样，我想每个人都知道。这是别人生活的集锦，展示了他们正在做的所有惊艳的事情。一天结束时，你很容易坐下来想，为什么我的生活没有那么完美？为什么我没有这个？为什么我没有这些经历？这可能是导致我们二十多岁时产生这种不快乐感的巨大推手。我想我们在节目中经常讨论这一点。
But this decade is a huge time in our lives for huge. massive life changes and transitions, relationships ending, losing loved ones, moving cities, losing jobs. These things really destabilize our life and some of the most stressful times that we will ever experience. There have been so many studies that have shown that things like moving even or losing someone or a breakup are potentially some of the most stressful things that you will experience and it takes a toll on our lives, it takes a toll on our happiness levels and our sense of stability and security. So I think you need to perhaps be gentle with yourself. If you're listening to this episode being like, I'm so unhappy and I don't know why because everything seems
但这个十年是我们生活中经历巨大、大规模生活变化和转型的关键时期，比如关系结束、失去亲人、搬到别的城市、失去工作。这些事情确实打破了我们生活的稳定，是我们经历过最具压力的时期之一。有如此多的研究表明，诸如搬家、失去某人或分手等事情，可能是你将经历最具压力的事，它对我们的生活、对我们的幸福感水平以及我们的稳定感和安全感造成了沉重打击。所以我想你也许需要对自己温柔一点。如果你在听这一集时觉得：我很不快乐，我不知道为什么，因为一切看起来都
to be going well, I think it's important to take a step back and think about, honestly think about and allow yourself to be almost a little bit selfish and a little bit pitying of what you may have been through in the last year, what you may have been through in the last six months, three months that has destabilized your life, even if it's been for the better. Things like leaving uni, things like moving cities or losing a loved one or going through a breakup, are going to create radical shifts in how we see the world and how our brain interacts with different stimuli and things in the world. And it's okay to experience unhappiness and a sense of sadness after these big changes. Our outlook as well determines so much of our emotional experiences and our emotional state.
进展顺利，我认为重要的是退后一步，认真思考并允许自己变得有点自私，有点同情自己在过去的一年、过去六个月、三个月里可能经历过的事情，这些经历打破了你的生活稳定，即使是为了变得更好。比如离开大学，比如搬到别的城市，或者失去亲人，或者经历分手，这些都将对我们看待世界的方式以及我们的大脑与世界上不同的刺激和事物的互动方式产生根本性的转变。在这些重大变化之后，体验到不快乐和悲伤的感觉是没问题的。我们的前景也决定了我们很大一部分的情感体验和情绪状态。
I think there are some people out there who are just genuinely more pessimistic about life. It has nothing to do with their levels of gratefulness or anything like that. It's just the same way that we're kind of born with the personality and we're born with the temperament. Some people, you know, come out of the womb and see the world as a little bit darker than it probably is the same way that some people come out and see the world a little bit brighter and are a bit more optimistic. Our outlook really does determine how we see the world. So it's important to kind of have a think about how do you interpret things when things go wrong versus when things go right for you.
我认为有些人天生对生活更加悲观。这与他们的感恩水平或诸如此类的事情毫无关联。这就像我们生来就带有某种个性，生来就带有某种气质是一样的。有些人，你知道的，一出生看到的世界就比它实际上的样子要阴暗一些，就像有些人一出生看到的世界要光明一些，更加乐观一样。我们的前景确实决定了我们如何看待世界。因此，想一想当事情出错时与事情对你进展顺利时你是如何解释的，这很重要。
You know, if things go wrong, do you think about it as, you know, this is my fault? Do you put it all down to an internal explanation of I am to blame, this is on me? And then when things go right, do you, you know, is your explanation around luck, around fate? It's really hard to feel happy and to feel satisfied when everything that go wrong is our fault, whereas everything that goes right is out of our control. There are so many factors that contribute to feeling sad and feeling unhappy and uneasy in our 20s. And they're definitely ones I've experienced and definitely ones that we have to do a bit of soul searching about. I think a biological explanation is one of them for sure. Like I think that's something I've been
你知道，如果事情出错了，你会认为这是，你知道的，这是我的错吗？你把这一切归咎于内部解释，认为是我在责无旁贷，这是我的责任吗？然后当事情进展顺利时，你知道的，你的解释是围绕着运气、围绕着命运吗？当所有出错的事都是我们的错，而所有顺利的事都超出了我们的控制时，要感到快乐和满足真的很难。有如此多的因素导致了我们在二十多岁时的悲伤、不快乐和不安。这些绝对是我经历过的，也绝对是我们必须进行一番灵魂深处探索的事。我认为生物学解释绝对是其中之一。就像我认为这是我一直
able to recognize is that sometimes our brains just don't produce what we need them to. And the kind of ripple on effects of that can be periods of really bad depression or periods of sadness. If that's something that you think you might be going through, like there are ways to get over that, but there are also cultural and environmental factors that contribute to our outlook on life. you know, the sense of doom around climate change is, or any other existential kind of crises or factors that are going on in your community or in your personal life or in the kind of global atmosphere as well can really impact our mental health in some very deeply unseen ways. And then there's things on a smaller scale, but that are just as impactful, like social media, like comparison. Comparison is kind of the thief of joy and with the rise in popularity of social media
能够认识到的一点，有时我们的大脑就是没有产生我们需要的东西。而随之产生的连锁反应可能是非常严重的抑郁期或悲伤期。如果你认为这可能是你正在经历的事情，那么有办法克服它，但也有文化和环境因素会导致我们对生活的看法。你知道，围绕气候变化的末日感，或是社区中、个人生活中或全球氛围中正在发生的任何其他存在主义危机或因素，都可能以某种非常隐秘的方式深刻影响我们的心理健康。然后还有一些较小规模但同样具有影响力的事物，比如社交媒体，比如比较。比较可以说是快乐的小偷，而随着社交媒体普及率的上升，
the ease of being able to see every moment of other people's lives it can really create quite a negative and toxic cycle that leaves us feeling really uneasy and really unhappy. I will say sometimes it feels good to be sad. I know that sounds kind of dumb, right? Like we're talking about how much it's a struggle to sometimes be unhappy and not have an explanation for it. But sometimes it's important to go through periods of sadness. I think that's why we listen to sad songs.
能够轻易看到别人生活的每一个时刻，真的会产生一个非常消极和有毒的循环，让我们感到非常不安和非常不快乐。我要说的是，有时难过感觉挺好的。我知道这听起来有点蠢，对吧？就像我们一直在讨论不快乐且找不到解释是一件多么痛苦的事情一样。但有时经历悲伤的时期是很重要的。我想这就是为什么我们听悲伤的歌。
I don't know, maybe you're not someone who likes to do that. But there is some kind of strange pleasure in the pain of listening to music that pulls at our heartstrings or that allows us to feel a little bit sorry for ourselves. There are some explanations around that. you know, it makes us feel nostalgic, but it also feels really human. It feels comforting that you can relate to someone else's experiences the way that they can relate to you. You know, it feels so much less alone when you're going through something really hard. You're in a period of deep unhappiness or sadness and you're able to hear that someone else has been through that as well. And not only have they been through that, but they've created something for you to relate to as
我不知道，也许你不是那种喜欢这样做的人。但在听那些触动我们心弦或让我们为自己感到有点遗憾的音乐时，痛苦之中确实有一种奇怪的快乐。围绕这一点有一些解释。你知道的，它让我们感到怀旧，但也感觉非常人性化。那种你能对别人的经历产生共鸣，就像他们能对你产生共鸣一样，会让人感到安慰。你知道，当你经历非常艰难的事情时，那种不孤单的感觉。当你处于深深的不快乐或悲伤时期，并且能够听到别人也经历过这些时。不仅他们经历过这些，而且他们还为你创造了可以产生共鸣的事物
well. I think that is a really important thing to remember. We all go through periods like this. It's completely normal. If you're someone listening to this right now in a really hard spot, you know, it sounds cliche, but you're not alone. It's actually really normal to go through this, especially in this decade of our lives. There are some of the biggest life changes that we will ever experience are happening right now. Right now, you know, so many big changes that create novel situations and novel experiences for us that we don't really understand because we've never been through them before. And the pressure that puts on our ability to adapt, on our resilience and on our brains and our outlooks and our perspectives is often so understated.
嗯，我认为这是非常重要的一点。我们都会经历这样的时期，这完全是正常的。如果你现在正在听这个节目，并且正处于一个非常艰难的时期，你知道，这听起来像是老生常谈，但你并不孤单。经历这一切其实非常正常，特别是在我们人生的这个十年里。我们即将经历的一些人生中最大的转变就发生在这时。此时此刻，你知道，这么多巨大的变化给我们带来了新奇的情境和体验，而我们并不真正理解它们，因为我们以前从未经历过。这种变化对我们适应能力、韧性、大脑、心态和视角的压力，往往被大大低估了。
You know, no wonder, I think all of us are bound to go through a hard point in this life. life. And I think we haven't even accounted for some of those other huge factors that you might be able to pinpoint, you know, losing a loved one, losing a job, going through a breakup. Like we said, these things destabilize us and they make it hard to see the joy and the beauty in life. And that sometimes contributes to this feeling of deep unhappiness and guilt associated with that, especially as privileged people, people who seemingly have everything. Or maybe you don't, but, you know, having a roof over your head and food and, you know, food in your belly and clothes on your back. Sometimes I think it's this sense of almost we're not allowed to feel bad.
你知道，难怪，我认为我们所有人都注定要在这个生活中经历一个艰难的关头。生活。而且我认为我们甚至还没有把其中一些其他巨大的因素考虑进去，你也许能够指出这些因素，比如失去亲人，失去工作，经历分手。就像我们说过的，这些事情打破了我们的平衡，让我们很难看到生活中的快乐和美丽。而这有时会导致这种深深的不快乐感以及与之相关的负罪感，特别是作为享有特权的人，那些表面上拥有一切的人。或者也许你没有，但是，你知道的，有遮风挡雨的地方和食物，你知道的，肚子里的食物和背上的衣服。有时我认为这几乎是一种我们不被允许感觉不好的感觉。
We're not allowed to feel unhappy because how lucky are we? Like, how lucky are we? And it kind of contributes to this societal feeling and the societal pressure of guilt and shame for not feeling grateful enough for not feeling like you really are blessed, which is so toxic, but you're allowed to feel unhappy even if you have everything that you could want, even if everything is going right. It's not always in your control, like our emotional states, like I said, sometimes just as much, even if less in our control as our external environment. There are so many things that are interacting in our brains and in our bodies and in our external worlds that impact our
我们不允许自己感到不开心，因为我们已经够幸运了，对吧？就像我们多幸运一样？这在某种程度上助长了一种社会情绪和社会压力，即当你觉得自己没有足够的感恩，没有觉得自己真正受到祝福时，会产生负罪感和羞耻感。这太有毒了，但你完全可以感到不开心，即使你拥有一切想要的东西，即使一切都进展顺利。这并不总是在你的控制之中，就像我们的情绪状态一样，正如我所说，有时候，它甚至和我们的外部环境一样，甚至更少受我们控制。有太多的因素在我们的大脑、身体和外部世界中相互作用，影响着我们
moods and impact our emotional states on a daily. So you don't need to feel a sense of guilt if you're not happy enough right now, if you're not appreciative enough of what you have. But I think it's important we also talk about how to move past this, how to change your outlook, how to change how you see the world to hopefully experience. experience a bit more happiness, this elusive word we've been talking about this whole episode, how do we curate our lives to be focused on happiness and focused on the achievement of happiness and joy and gratitude? That's what we're going to talk about in the next segment of this episode. Something that is so important to remember is that everything is temporary.
每天的情绪和情感状态。所以，如果你现在不够快乐，如果你对拥有的东西不够感激，你不需要感到内疚。但我认为，我们同样需要讨论如何超越这一点，如何改变你的视角，如何改变你看待世界的方式，从而有望体验到更多一点的快乐——这个我们在整集节目中一直在讨论的难以捉摸的词。我们该如何精心策划我们的生活，使其专注于快乐、专注于实现快乐、喜悦和感恩呢？这就是我们在本集接下来的部分中要讨论的内容。有一点非常重要，必须记住，那就是一切都是暂时的。
Every experience, every emotional experience is completely temporary. The same goes for unhappiness. The same goes for sadness. I remember when I was younger, my mom used to say to me, the only thing promised is change. And sometimes that is a really scary thought. But when it comes to periods like this one, where you might be really unhappy,
每一种经历，每一种情感体验都完全是暂时的。不开心也是如此，悲伤也是如此。我记得当我年轻的时候，我妈妈经常对我说，唯一得到承诺的就是改变。有时这真是一个可怕的想法。但当遇到像这样的时期，你可能真的非常不开心，
where things just like aren't looking up when you're really stuck in a rut, it's kind of a really amazing reminder that life promises, you that things will change and hopefully it can't get much worse like there really is up there the only way really is up and there are things that you can do to help yourself get there so many things we always say this on the show you have agency you have the ability to make small changes in your life and although periods of sadness and periods of depression even or unhappiness aren't
当事情看起来毫无起色，当你真的陷入困境时，这其实是一个非常棒的提醒，生活向你承诺事情会发生变化，而且希望情况不会变得更糟——情况真的只会向上走，唯一的出路就是向上，而且你可以采取一些行动来帮助自己到达那里。我们在节目中总是这样说：你有自主权，你有能力在生活中做出微小的改变。尽管悲伤时期、甚至抑郁或不快乐的时期
always within our control there are things we can do to kind of ease the pain a little bit And that's what I want to talk about now. I want to talk about some strategies, some methods for overcoming a period like this one, where you just don't feel particularly happy. Okay, I'm going to say something really cliche here. But therapy is incredible. It's amazing. Like, there's a reason that everyone, you know, it talks about getting therapy and everyone talks about how amazing and important it is to receive psychological help.
并不总是在我们的控制范围之内，但我们可以做一些事情来稍微缓解这种痛苦。这就是我接下来要谈论的内容。我想讨论一些策略、一些方法，来度过这样一段你感觉不到特别快乐的时期。好吧，我要说一句非常老套的话：但心理治疗太不可思议了。太棒了。你看，每个人都在讨论寻求心理治疗，每个人都在讨论接受心理帮助是多么棒、多么重要，这是有原因的。
I really cannot overstate the best. benefits. I know it can be expensive. I know it can be inaccessible. And I know that not everyone has the same access as others in being able to receive this help. But if you are someone who does have access to it, if you're someone who is eligible for a certain program or is eligible for therapy or psychological assistance through work, you should absolutely do it. Even if you don't think anything is clinically wrong with you, even if you're just not feeling all right, you're just feeling a little bit off. It is still so, so important. I think going to therapy and receiving professional help in times like this, in times when everything just doesn't, you know, things don't seem to be
我真的怎么强调它的好处都不为过。我知道它可能很昂贵，我知道它可能难以企及，我也知道并不是每个人都能像其他人一样获得这种帮助。但如果你是一个有条件获得这种帮助的人，如果你是一个符合某个项目资格的人，或者通过工作有资格获得心理治疗或心理援助的人，你绝对应该去做。即使你认为自己没有任何临床问题，即使你只是感觉不太对劲，只是觉得有点不对劲。这依然非常非常重要。我认为在这样的时刻——当一切都似乎没有，你知道的，事情似乎没有
looking up, when it really has nothing to do with what's going on in your life. It seems to be more internal. Going to therapy provides, provides a place free of judgment in a way that, talking to friends and talking to family doesn't always offer you. People are always going to bring their own assessments of you and perceptions of you into any conversation about mental health or any conversation about what's going on in your life. But a therapist is not the same. It doesn't have, they don't have that same, that same bias or those same preconceived notions of you. It's a place completely free of judgment and shame. That's like what they're paid to do. They're paid to just listen to you. And you're able to really focus almost selfishly on just you, on just what you want to
好转的时候，当它真的与你的生活现状无关，而似乎更多是内在问题时，去接受心理治疗和专业帮助，能提供一个免受判断的场所。这种感觉是与朋友和家人交谈时并不总能感受到的。人们在进行任何关于心理健康的对话，或任何关于你生活现状的对话时，总是会把他们对你的评估和看法带入其中。但治疗师则不同。他们没有那种同样的偏见或对你的既定看法。这是一个完全没有判断和羞耻的场所。这就是他们的工作职责。他们拿报酬就是为了倾听你的心声。你能够真正近乎自私地只关注你自己，只关注你想
talk about, on just what you're feeling. That is so rare. You don't get that in every other day-to-day experience of life. But when you do go and receive professional help, that's the whole point. Like, you are kind of the star of the show. You get to talk about whatever you want to talk about, free of judgment. And we don't always get that opportunity. I think. also they provide you with some amazing strategies for changing your outlook and changing daily habits in your life that might help you out. I do want to say I really hate this idea of almost toxic positivity or lifestyle changes as a way to get better if you're going through a hard period. I think often people talk about the endorphins release from exercise and eating well
谈论的内容，只关注你的感受。这太难得了。你在日常生活的其他经历中是得不到这种体验的。但当你真正去接受专业帮助时，这才是核心所在。就像，你是整场表演的主角。你可以谈论任何你想谈论的事情，免受评判。我们并不总是有这样的机会。我认为。他们还会为你提供一些极好的策略，帮助你改变观看世界的视角，改变你生活中可能对你有所帮助的日常习惯。我必须说，我很讨厌这种近乎有毒的积极性，或者把生活方式的改变作为度过艰难时期的唯一好方法。我认为人们经常谈论运动和吃得好释放的内啡肽，
and doing things that make you happy and, you know, doing things that make you feel connected with others. And those are definitely an important part of the equation. It is difficult to be happy if you don't connect with those around you and if you don't spend time outside and drink enough water and take care of your body. But that's not always going to be the solution. And like we said, this episode is really about those times when you are doing all of those things. You're doing everything right and you still don't feel completely okay. So I do really want to dispel this idea that simple lifestyle changes are going to cure everything you're going through. Sometimes that is, you know, the simplest explanation isn't the best one and sometimes it's not always in our
以及做那些让你快乐的事情，你知道的，做那些让你感到与他人有连接的事情。这些绝对是公式中重要的一部分。如果你不与周围的人建立联系，如果你不花时间去户外、喝足够的水并照顾好自己的身体，你就很难感到快乐。但这并不总是解决方案。就像我们说过的，这一集主要探讨的是当你已经做了所有这些事情时的那些时刻。你每件事都做对了，但你仍然感觉不完全好。所以我真的很想消除这种误解，即简单的生活方式的改变就能治愈你经历的一切。有时，你知道的，最简单的解释并不是最好的解释，而且有时这并不总在我们
control. But it's also important to give yourself a bit of a fighting chance, right? And to try the things that you think might work, the things that may have worked in the past. And that kind of links to the next point. There is something to be said about finding small joys throughout your day and reflecting on them, especially when you feel like things aren't really going your way, like you have this inexplicable kind of black cloud lingering over your head. You can decide to think about what's going right. Think about what there is to be grateful for. And it's not in a way of shaming yourself or making yourself feel guilty for not appreciating those things before. It's just a nice reminder. Sometimes when we're kind of stuck in the mud and we're kind of stuck in
控制之中。但给自己一个争取改变的机会也很重要，对吧？去尝试那些你认为可能有效的事情，那些过去可能管用的事情。这就引出了下一个观点。关于在日常生活中发现小确幸并对其进行反思，有很多值得探讨的地方，尤其是当你觉得事情不顺心，仿佛头顶挥之不去一朵阴郁的乌云时。你可以决定去想想什么事情进展顺利。想想有什么值得感恩的。这并不是为了羞耻自己，也不是为了因为以前没有感激这些事情而感到内疚。这只是一个美好的提醒。有时，当我们陷入泥潭，陷入
the dark times of our lives, it can be really difficult to poke our heads up and really survey the landscape and survey our lives from an honest perspective and realize how much we have. So it's important, I think, to maintain some form of gratitude list or gratitude journal. My really good friend Zoe does this. And I remember when I was going through a really hard time, maybe a couple of years ago, she told me to give it a go. And I really didn't believe her. I kind of shook it off. I was like, oh, that's not going to do anything. But let me tell you, even just that small practice of forcing myself to list five, ten things I'm grateful for every day, it changes, it changes your outlook on life. And it also causes you to search for those things. It causes you to go out into the
我们生命中的黑暗时期时，我们很难抬起头来，真正从诚实的角度审视我们的风景和生活，并意识到我们拥有多少东西。因此，我认为保持某种形式的感恩清单或感恩日记非常重要。我非常好的朋友佐伊就在这样做。我记得几年前我经历一段非常艰难的时期时，她让我试一试。我当时其实并不相信她。我有点不以为然，心想，哦，那根本起不到任何作用。但老实说，哪怕只是强迫自己每天列出五到十件让我感恩的事情这样一个小小练习，它也会改变你对生活的看法。它也会促使你去寻找那些东西。它会促使你走到
world and day by day think about things that are going to make you feel grateful for for another day, make you feel grateful for the life that you live. I remember I think when I was going through a hard period at the start of the year, one day the only thing that I was grateful for was like a chicken salad, which is so sad. I was like, oh, I'm so grateful for this chicken salad. But you know what? How beautiful is that that I was able to find just that one thing? And it was so simple. It was so basic and I think about it quite a lot like that it's such a beautiful practice to put your mind to. I also think it's important to recognize the environmental and social and cultural factors in our lives that may be contributing to unhappiness. Specifically, things that are pulling us down,
世界中去，日复一日地思考那些会让你为新的一天感到感恩、为你所过的生活感到感恩的事情。我记得在今年年初我经历艰难时期的时候，有一天我唯一感恩的事竟然是一份鸡肉沙拉，这太悲哀了。当时我想，哦，我太感激这份鸡肉沙拉了。但你知道吗？我能够仅仅找到这唯一的一件小事，是多么美好的一件事啊？它是如此简单，如此基础，我经常回想它——这真是一个值得用心去体会的绝佳练习。我也认为，认清生活中可能导致不快乐的环境、社会和文化因素非常重要。具体来说，那些把我们拉入低谷的事物，
whether that is toxic relationships or toxic friendships or a toxic workplace, you don't have to stay in environments and in relationships that don't allow you to grow. You don't have to stay in stressful situations that are taking away from your ability to live the life you want to leave. Like, this is your life. You really only get one of them. So if there is something like that in your life, something that is wearing you down, something that you think is subconsciously or consciously making you feel sad or making you unhappy or making you stressed, you're allowed to change that. You're allowed to say no and you're allowed to remove those things from your life. There's also a lot to be said about this practice of almost scheduling happiness and scheduling
无论是充满毒性的恋爱关系、充满毒性的友谊，还是充满毒性的工作场所，你都不必停留在那些不允许你成长的环境和关系中。你不需要忍受那些剥夺你过上想要的生活能力的压力情境。听着，这就是你的生活。你真的只有这一生。所以，如果你的生活中确实存在这样一类东西，某种正在消磨你意志的事物，某种你认为在潜意识或意识中让你感到悲伤、不快乐或充满压力的东西，你完全可以改变它。你有权说不，也有权将这些东西从你的生活中剔除出去。关于几乎将快乐和
pleasure into your life. It's a psychological practice. I think that's what it's called. I think it's called gratitude scheduling or pleasure scheduling. So essentially, you schedule activities throughout your week and throughout your day that you know are going to make you happy. So be that signing up for a gym class in three days, you know, that's something to look forward to. Or saying to yourself, you know, oh, if I go into the office or if I see a friend today or if I leave my house today and go for a walk, I'm going to let myself get a really nice cup of coffee or a really nice sweet treat.
愉悦排入日程表的这种做法，也有很多值得探讨的地方。这是一种心理学实践。我想这就是它的名字。我想它被称为感恩排期或愉悦排期。因此，本质上，你会在你的周计划和日常生活中安排那些你知道会让你快乐的活动。比如三天后报名参加一个健身班，你知道，这是值得期待的事情。或者对自己说，你知道的，哦，如果我今天去办公室，或者如果我今天见一个朋友，或者如果我今天离开家去散步，我就允许自己买一杯非常棒的咖啡或一个非常美味的甜点。
You get to decide the pleasure and happiness that enters into your life, and it's a really great way to retrain your brain into understanding the agency that you have over your emotional experiences. And that's not all the time. You know, there are always going to be instances in which things come out of the blue and really traumatic and awful experience happen that destabilize our lives and kind of push us around, and shift out and shift our outlook and shift our ability to cope. But when you build that resilience and when you build those strategies throughout your life
你可以决定进入你生活的快乐与幸福，这是重新训练你的大脑、让你理解自己对情感体验拥有自主权的一种绝妙方式。当然，并非所有时刻都能如此。你知道，总会有突如其来的情况发生，非常痛苦和可怕的经历打破了我们的生活平衡，把我们推来搡去，改变我们的视角，削弱我们的应对能力。但是，当你建立起这种韧性，当你一生中不断建立起这些策略
to be able to deal with those moments, you will emerge as a stronger person. Before we wrap up, I do just want to say, I really hope that we talk about this more and that this episode allows you to talk to your family and friends about this more. I'm going through a period right now where from the outside, I'm sure people think everything is going really amazingly well. And for many, many reasons it is and in many ways it is. But that doesn't mean that I'm not allowed to feel unhappy and that same can be said for you. You don't always get to control how you feel about experiences. And sometimes even when things are going really well, that can be incredibly overwhelming if that's not something that you expect or if it's a real surprise.
来应对那些时刻时，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更坚强的人。在结束之前，我只想说，我真的希望我们能更多地讨论这个话题，也希望这一集能让你与家人和朋友更多地探讨它。我现在正经历这样一段时期：从外表来看，大家肯定觉得一切都进展得非常顺利。由于许多许多原因，事实也确实如此，在许多方面确实如此。但这并不意味着我不允许自己感到不快乐，你也是一样。你并不总是能控制自己对各种经历的感受。有时，即使事情进展得非常顺利，如果你对此没有心理准备，或者这纯粹是个意外，那也会让人感到极其不知所措。
You're allowed to be overwhelmed and you're allowed to take time to process your experiences and what's going on in your life and above all else you're allowed to be unhappy, but I don't think you have to be. And if it's something you're seriously struggling with, I think go and get professional help. There's absolutely no shame in doing that. I think it's honestly something to be applauded and something that's. incredibly brave. You're deciding for you, that you want to be better, that you want to be happier. And that is just so incredible. So rarely do people actively make the choice to put themselves first and to improve their life. So if you have any doubt or if you have any desire
你完全可以感到不知所措，也可以花时间去处理你的经历以及你生活中的种种状况，最重要的是，你完全可以不开心，但我认为你不必一直不开心。如果你正在严重地为此苦恼，我认为你应该去寻求专业帮助。这样做绝对没有任何羞耻感。老实说，我认为这值得鼓掌，这是一件极其勇敢的事情。你是在为自己做决定，你希望变得更好，你希望变得更快乐。这简直太不可思议了。人们很少会主动做出把自我放在首位、去改善自己生活的选择。所以，如果你有任何疑虑，或者你有任何渴望
to do it, I would really say, go and do it. Go and do it now. Do it as soon as possible. And I think that you will really be better for it. You know, it's probably something I need to do as well. So it's a good reminder to me. And I just want to say thank you so much for listening to this episode. And if this is something you're going through, I'm sending you so much love and so much support and so much strength. Just by listening to this, I'm sure that you are already thinking about ways to kind of to help yourself. And I also hope this eases some of your guilt. You know, it's not always something that you've done and something that you need to change. They're a biological and cultural and environmental and existential things that are impacting us on a daily, it can be really
去做的冲动，我真的想对你说，去吧，现在就去。尽快去做。我想这真的会让你的状况大为改观。你知道，这可能也是我需要做的事情。所以这对我自己也是一个很好的提醒。我只想说，非常感谢大家收听这一集。如果你正经历这样的时期，我向你送去满满的爱、满满的支持和满满的力量。仅仅通过收听这个节目，我相信你已经在思考如何帮助自己了。我也希望这能减轻你的一些内疚感。你知道，这并不总是你做错了什么、需要你去改变什么。有些生物学、文化、环境和存在主义的因素每天都在影响着我们，当所有这些其他事情同时发生时，要保持一种幸福感并
hard to remain true to a sense of happiness and to achieve happiness in our lives when all these other things are going on and you're doing an amazing job. So thank you for listening to this episode. Thank you for supporting the show, each and every one of you. It's so great to have you here. And if you do feel inclined, if this was something that you enjoyed, please feel free to leave the show a five-star review. It really helps the podcast grow. It helps the show grow. If it's something that you think someone else would benefit from, that would also be amazing.
在生活中获得快乐，真的非常困难，而你们已经做得非常棒了。所以感谢大家收听本期节目。感谢每一位支持这个节目的人。很高兴能有你们的陪伴。如果你愿意的话，如果你喜欢这个节目，请随手给节目留下一个五星好评。这真的对播客的成长很有帮助，对节目的发展大有裨益。如果你觉得其他人也能从中受益，那那就更棒了。
And as always, I will see you next week for another episode. Thank you for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilient. in our strange modern world.
一如既往，我们下周同一时间再见。感谢收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇怪的现代世界中保持精神坚韧、体能和建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。这就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上的“2%”。在《回顾过去》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会带你回到过去，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《回顾过去》播客。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都根本不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披重重盔甲？这向世界释放出一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《艰难学习》。
This is an IHart podcast, Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客，保证真人制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。